ce 28 juin est un sombre jour pour la
démocratie à sens avec seulement 31 %
je considère que c'est très préoccupant
que ces mêmes grave que ça devrait
inviter toutes les listes et que ça
devrait inviter la candidate sortante
marie louise fort a beaucoup d'humidité
parce que quand on est élu avec si peu
d'électeurs évidemment que les six
années qui viennent ne seront pas les
mêmes
c'est la seule leçon que je tire de ce
scrutin qui était un non sens à mon sens
démocratique puisque le gouvernement
avec cette sa décision de maintenir le
premier tour le 15 mars et d'organiser
un second tour le 28 juin
finalement a fait déserter les électeurs
soient qui ont pris peur donc à cause de
la crise sanitaire soit qui ont été
déconnectées de ces élections après
trois mois de coupure
donc nous on avait plébiscité évidemment
on était partisan d'un report général de
ces élections il en est pas été le cas
et là on voit le résultat qui est
désastreux d'un point de vue
démocratique